welcome ladies and gentlemen to another
episode of riffin with Griffin we're
here again at all things comedy studio
and I am you know once again I'm still
looking for a theme song I have another
one but before I go into another theme
song let me introduce my friend my
colleague mr. RJ Tyler hola como estas
see I'm trying my Spanish what's up it's
good I really is good to have you now I
know as you know I say I I have these
theme songs that I do and these people
send them in and this one's another one
it's just the same one from the same guy
from last week it's matic productions I
believe I don't know if I said that
right but the dudes dope and he made one
for me last week on for the before the
Bobby Lee episode or the week or
whatever whenever this comes out I don't
know if I have a episode in-between this
one but anyway here's another theme song
for riff Nick with Griffin hmm
you can't hear you get your headphones
on Madeira
[Music]
Oh Jake I lay here River with Griffin
trooper Griffin all right this is what
happens when you let you can tell me I'm
too old Eric you're sixteen sixteen at
heart yeah
um well it's good to see you I haven't
seen you since unfortunately our show
was canceled yeah you know I'm dying up
here I couldn't handle her sauce I don't
know what happened it's just a travesty
but all right though it is what it is
yeah I feel I feel I'm a little rocky
about it like it still bother me but I'm
still happy because we put some good ass
[ __ ]
yeah it wasn't our fault we really did
good yeah I really I meant everybody all
right I love everything we did together
hmm you know it's like it was our part
yeah above and beyond goddamn it hey
yeah we do really did our part but I
mean like I say you know there's so many
factors that go into what make a show
good you've been on a lot of stuff
though yeah I mean let's see scream
right loved white boy Rick thank you
yeah that would that was good perfect
for you
we're gonna talk about all that and what
what's another you did I'm dying up here
yeah and then he did Vice Principals you
were great on that yeah you've done so
many things yeah and you have these like
real humble beginnings Jacksonville
Florida born and raised
it's my city man and my babies right
before they're in the house or in the
building in the building because it
might not be a house it's true
especially from Jacksonville yeah now is
it not is it true that you were
discovered in a mall what see this is
just like the story I hear like you was
walking through the mall that's crazy
yeah and then like they've mistaken me
for like and they had like the casting
hey how did all J Carly get discovered I
don't know let's just put the perfect
yeah yeah sure up of how a young
african-american kid would make it you
were walking through the Jacksonville
mall what's the real story how did you
get to LA I stone active I was sleep
right in the backseat of my Paul van we
was on the way home from church right
and only me and him went to Sunday
because my mom's was sick and so heard
this commercial that was like do you
want your kids to be on Disney Channel
and work with stars such as oh no no no
no no and of course all of these stars
are people that are you know followed
heavy I used to watch Disney Channel
like it was reading the Bible you know
every team social Church everything that
was my church and I'm on time ready with
my tithes and offerings alright so like
when I heard it I got extra hype you
know I'm saying and the thought of a
scam never will come to kids mind you
know I write a Disney we thing and you
think it's on radio yeah yeah why would
they put a scam why would they do that
okay that's like saying that the
government lies to us why would they do
that so you hear it you're just like it
did the like okay and so I told my like
I started just getting on my part was
like hey I want to do it cuz I was half
sleepy and so he was like boy should go
back to sleep but what did the
commercials say like what he would have
to do no you just had to uh it was like
send in like your picture and email or
whatever so they could send you like the
brochure and packet and stuff oh okay
r'mante right from Disney Channel he
plays Esteban Julio
that's a lot of syllables and and so it
was held by him so that was something
also that just took me like okay Esteban
is holding something cool and so my dad
was like boys to scam cuz he's my
partner right he's from Florida
Jacksonville who the hell gonna come to
jackieo j rj real you you really did
come on son
and I was like you know I'm stubborn and
so I really wanted it so then when he
said no I went straight to my queen my
mama I was like hey mom was all about it
she was a body body God dang it
and so I started going I went to the to
the showcase or whatever did it and then
after that I got signed with chrome town
the agency but wait wait wait you sent
your picture yeah yeah and then you had
to go into like this uh we got this
thing he didn't get called in did you
you said to picture you yes it was an
open call go yeah yeah I was open call
yeah okay sweet and so um when I went
and I seen that it was like oh [ __ ] is a
whole bunch of other kids in here damn
like everybody it was like American Idol
audition is Richie I met one of my best
friends his name is Aaron and it's just
like when we first started the program
is just like something we get bored
quickly sorry y'all have to keep our
attention and so it was like going
through the whole situation we got I got
signing in Orlando didn't forget it out
sign in Orlando cuz they never hit me
all they did was just took $700 for a
photo shoot and no that's the scam but
they crazy that the crazy thing is those
heroes okay no no those photos are like
oh my IMDB like man they've been there
that's that's your main it was you and
it wasn't this now
but it's like it's like okay cool and so
then they close down as a as a agency
but I was still cool with the dude that
was my agent I was like alright cool so
he still keeps her with me nowadays just
you know really cool then came out to LA
cuz okay so wait wait so you went to
this yeah that wasn't that was in
Jackson that was in Jackson you went to
the open call and then what happened
from there though they they said yes sir
yeah yeah they were like hey we dig your
son and Adrian was like hey we just
really wanted him in a program and then
that's when that's when the scam
happened in a sense what that's what the
most think you would be a that's when I
saw you in 700 officer pictures okay got
you but but and so when me and my mom
went to talk to Adrian or whatever he
was just like don't worry about that the
cost of the program just get him in here
you know right right right getting me to
take care and that was the first time I
was just like all right this makes you
way more than just a celebrity that I
see on TV that you don't want to meet
like alright cool son you believe in
something although you believe in me but
you believe in something so he gave me
so that was your first time to you felt
like okay maybe I can do yeah I was like
I just met guys yeah I'm good right
alright that's cool and so then I did
that program came out here to edit it
was the program it's called CG TV well
it was called CG TV was it like Cole
reading you're like auditioning yeah it
was how long did you do that I did
effort through I think it was three
weeks but I did I was an intensive yeah
but it wasn't everyday it was only on
the weekends okay okay yeah cuz nobody
would come out everything yeah so you
did like a three week three weekends
yeah he worked on auditioning and
reading and acting yeah okay and then I
read for my agents now I'm at the
showcase that they have in LA so he was
okay and so came out here for the
showcase and that's why I met my agent
Kendall Park and he's the realest G that
I've ever met I love you can do so much
because the first thing he said to me
wasn't hey it wasn't what's up it wasn't
I love you work it was [ __ ] everybody
else you talking to me and that was the
first thing he ever said out his mouth
to me and I was like
mom we targeted is this I he's black and
Asian he's Blake this blasian dude
because he said [ __ ] everybody else and
everybody else has been on some like
high you thought enough often to that
authenticity man like for real for real
and I and not to say like I didn't have
a like a sense of good judgment right
but you know every agent in LA is good
at that [ __ ] they support I say you're
like a it's like it's like you feel a
little [ __ ] every but we Kendall
it was no [ __ ] no way he was just
good it was just like hey look I've know
exactly what the [ __ ] you need kit and
if you want it I'd give it to you if you
don't you can go [ __ ] with somebody
else
he was right he was so [ __ ] right and
then would you read for first I read for
a bunch of commercials me and Kendall
were first strictly gotcha and then I
had another manager who cut me off of
his roster cuz I was a few days late and
I was I was also in school at the time
that I was doing this so I'm like what
how old yeah yeah I'm like 7 what 17 18
yeah graduate high school you know and
also like I'm not a part of this
industry so it's a lot that I don't know
right and as a kid I'm like dog I need
to focus on graduating and I also don't
get money to like make sure that my mama
good mom dad I got [ __ ] boy and I wasn't
even that late and the thing was he cut
me off of his roster he was like I'm
unprofessional this and that I was like
okay cool and so Kendall called my nerve
in like 30 seconds was like alright good
I'll call you back in a little bit right
he calls me back in five minutes it was
like art you got to read with Nick and
Nick is also a part of JLA so when I met
Nick I was just like cool I like you but
I need a manager done' and then they
introduced me to Steven and Judy who are
my managers you know still today still
to this day we've been rocking and
smacking his [ __ ] since and it's like
you know my old manager he tried to you
know come back and try them like [ __ ]
you boy yeah yeah you gonna hate me from
now on in Hollywood and I promise you
that boy cuz like it all it took was for
you to like be patient with a kid that
did you know he was new to this
you know yeah I didn't know [ __ ] now
imma steal everything from your client
like I'm serious like and that's the
thing and it's because you spit on my
dream before you even let me try to show
you that I could do this [ __ ] you know
I'm saying even though you know my like
it's jacket even still it still bothers
you yeah it's that boy pisses me off but
it also makes me happy right as hell cuz
it's like in that in that moment my
faith was shooken cuz it's like alright
cool God you got me witness manager so
why would you let him like spit me out
the trash like it's nothing you know and
he was just like oh well because that
wasn't the right one wasn't to see if
you trusted me Brodie and I was like you
know what you crate next time just ask
me if I trust you I will say yes like
Jesus Christ don't take me do that
anymore you know and it's like no bad
smoke but like you know don't don't you
can't come my way like so you get so now
you got the manager you got the new
manager you got the new agent we got em
in Hollywood now did you decide to did
you guys move to Hollywood are y'all
just staying in Halle no we was moved
here about in oh yeah oh really I am so
you went to the three week program after
the three week program in that you told
your parents we got to go to LA well I
said I will move to LA you go to LA
right now it seems like so your dad you
and your dad came out no I mean my mom
came are you okay okay because your dad
stay back yes out to be wrong and so it
was it was cool cuz that that first time
of me and my mom being away from
Jacksonville you know I'm saying
especially on this level it was like
alright mama I'm all you got
you all like that you know I'm saying it
was just like if a zombie apocalypse
broke out it was the only species the
doggy one the one man like me and my
mom's I've met your mom love your mom is
like like it's crazy like when your
parents were come to said they just so
like
yes matic and fun about babies you
almost got to be like hey you you cannot
go
yeah they see fun okay so I'm shooting
over here so now you out here with your
mom and then you read for the8 you guys
how you got to agent and all that yeah
and then so soon after that what was the
first thing first name was me and Earl
and the dying girl
well first homeless was the like we were
staying in motel 6 and between our truck
for a little bit you know I'm saying
just the beginning you know think of
just you were living in a truck with
your mom yes a Toyota Highlander that
[ __ ] was burgundy I had a few
scratches
it had LoJack so they used to cut that
[ __ ] off because we couldn't pay the
bill for it all the time and so they cut
it off the last time and my dad was like
you know what [ __ ] it I don't want to
deal with this no more and so he left it
at the you know at the oxnard crib and
he was like y'all got to come get it we
need it no y'all gotta come get it
Wow you know I so man this isn't this is
this is incredible okay it really is
okay so you here with your mom you
living in a truck you're going in and
out of hotels just on a dream just on an
on the idea that I believe in myself so
thoroughly and the fact we're gonna make
this happen so yeah you booked that
first role with which was me and Earl
and a girl
oh yeah that's my baby yeah you always
remember that your life that changed my
whole life
and and not even just like because it
kind of pushed my trajectory towards
like my dream right but it showed me how
much faith can walk you know I'm saying
it just showed me like how much RJ if
you just trust me bro like that's why so
many of my decisions now and so many of
my like problems and worries and [ __ ]
they just breeze off my shoulder that's
because he's shown his self before right
especially on this big ass love like all
right RJ right now you got both your
parents in LA you got your dad working
but you don't really got a job trying to
do bar mitzvahs and stuff of 50 to 100
dollars you know I'm saying by the way
by the way you can't just put that out
there by the way what my man here is a
DJ yeah the story line yeah but at what
point so you were always a DJ though
yeah yeah I've been DJing since like the
sixth grade okay right okay so that so
that was always like in your mind
you were like you know if all else fails
I'll be able this is my fallback that's
stand up for me
yeah so for you as being a deejay yeah
okay so you now so not only that now is
your mom like hauling crates or records
for you y'all DJing together is like
they're with you at the parties like how
did that work out at first
no at first so I used to we had a
roommate named Matt day right and so
well he used to be my roommate now he's
my brother
like I burn this city down but so
Matthew he asks me one day when he came
in the crib this after we had met he was
like a load literally do you want a job
and I was like yeah so that's when I get
with this DJ company h2h and it was the
first time that I was like all right
cool I can do something I'll make money
and I know I'm about to have [ __ ] fun
doing it I'm saying like okay so you see
the DJ gig is in full effect
yeah in and out as you're trying to
before you hear yeah before I get I was
working at h2h before I even get Earl
for a minute you know I'm saying like
and I was like all right cool let's do
this
so the homeless little situation that
was good three four months but it was
cool because we went through a lot of
like funny ass moments at this hotel
like I didn't even go cab it was like it
was fun as [ __ ] I can't even imagine
living in a truck with my mom it's not
listen conversation right coming in late
you'd be back at this truck by 12
o'clock in every window in this bit like
no wake up but she's looking back at you
like what are you doing yeah it's funny
but it was so cool because now did I
take so much stuff seriously you know
I'm saying like I don't take [ __ ] for
granted now not even from there like
smallest no tell me the moment though
mmm that when you found out you booked
this gig were you in the truck with your
mom no we was actually and we're worried
we was in Missouri with Broderick so my
brother was graduating from the military
he graduated from the military the same
day that I got carded I booked his movie
so that was like a double whammy oh
that's great and like it we were
err and I'm like a boy like what's good
I'm just happy to see him you know right
and so as we were driving to go get food
after we had seen him graduate or
whatever
they called me I screamed like a girl my
daddy swerved a little bit like like on
suggestion cuz it was out of nowhere I
was like oh like you know I'm high why
of course
I'm like unbelievable so then like the
whole I bet everybody even what was your
brother like though your brother might
have been like a little soupy no okay
cuz his day there you go come no no
that's the thing no he was just he was
just his height right just because he
knows when it come to me in project we
kind of like the left and right ball you
know I'm saying it's like it were you
going with this no listen listen you
can't have one without the other kind of
you know I'm saying it's like that
that's my boy so it in that moment he
was just happy that we was there right
and so when I called him after cuz he
wasn't driving he was with you guys yeah
yeah cuz we left him there yet take care
and so I even told him he was like yeah
like he was hype like my brothers were
hype as hell the only time that they
kind of threw me and shook me was when I
booked Power Rangers cuz they didn't say
congratulations they just said don't
[ __ ] this up but that's just gonna be no
I always I know I was so pissed I was
like yo y'all not gonna say
congratulations the first thing alright
cool alright alright whatever
so when you got Earl so now you're in
the middle of that life changes a little
bit cuz now like you know that first
check you were like why are we gonna be
able to yeah I can get we can rent we
can rent something that actually live
live live proper mm-hmm you know at
least like get them something to where
they comfortable I just want my babies
to be comfortable I don't need all that
extra you know extravagance because they
don't they get annoyed with that [ __ ]
they hate when I buy them a jewelry you
know they country estate or like yo out
and bought them jewelry pieces and they
just yeah rather you get her like a
stainless steel pot does she can like
you know and or night yeah good knife
you know whole [ __ ] Ginsu say
oh that's why I can't fight my mama dogs
do good with knives yeah I feel bad for
anybody that try their lady so you you
book Earl and then this all changed and
then after that now you it's
everything's history after that right
what was next after that after Earl was
this tobacco-free commercial yes I love
that commercial I actually met one of my
best friend's my mom like oh my gosh
so when I met Maya it was honest on the
set right and at the time I was just
like you have such a like crazy good ass
energy like just being like there right
but now she's just this epitome of just
sauce if that makes sense like what
that's what is so [ __ ] cool I'm just
like my I love you my home but you have
a lot of you you just have an energy
about you that you you are it's like you
will you are the entourage type guy but
not in a bad way it's just that you like
having people around you you know you
from Jacksonville Florida you got a big
family you like having family around you
so you like you have these you know
people that come around you but have you
experienced it being like oh I got to
get this person out of my life oh hell
yeah
you don't trust hell yeah that's [ __ ]
that's 85% of this wall cuz it's like
everybody you always got a question like
what you want from me you know I'm
saying like it's unfortunate though it's
unfortunate but then you also have to
find that that balance of like alright
this person actually don't want [ __ ]
other than just a bday you know and it's
really funny and I found it I'm not
gonna say that I haven't cuz I found
that you know here in LA with with a lot
of people some you know older from when
I just got here you know in some more
recent and it's cool to find that
because
it's so fake I hear oh my gosh
compared to Jacksonville you can plant
in jak culture shock I look the awesome
G [ __ ] in Jacksonville right if somebody
don't like you you gonna know that they
don't like your ass
alright that's just it that's just
that's point blank period and also
there's no entitlement to respect in
Jacksonville just like you have
to be like you have to give to your
community to get that from you you know
community it's like don't feel that in
la la everybody is entitled to they
think everything yeah it's like I'm
entitled to this M&R and I don't do you
not when do they get British in LA to
say I'm just saying that's the that's my
passion is let me let me speak you do
you know you sound like this is my hand
to hold the [ __ ] on how did how dare you
how Dinah bougie
you think I'm bushi so bougie you are
the cutest blonde dude okay let's get
back to you [ __ ]
okay um alright so you get the
commercial you get Earl and then like
things really start you know the heating
up right because now did you get you did
you get I'm dying up here around that
time at the same time you got Power
Rangers because I know you were film
were you filming Power Rangers at the
same time filming I'm diner I was
filming war machine at war machine right
that's what it was yeah I came to Brad
Pitt
I came from Abu Dhabi to film that [ __ ]
was crazy I remember seeing an article
like offer I first booked a role in
outside oh yeah it was all the things I
had to go through and then I just see
this article like you know RJ Kyler you
know from such-and-such
[ __ ] what is this gonna be right yeah
yeah so you see did war machine you
working with Brad Pitt and all that yeah
I mean this is crazy to me it's crazy
it's crazy because you went from a radio
commercial a radio commercial to like
moving to LA the tobacco commercial and
now you working with Brad Pitt yeah all
in like what a year two years six months
uh no that was three three and a half
years three and a half years or in the
process of yes because you wore in that
show yeah yeah I got you okay so you do
that then you then then you got your
doing war machine with war machine so
war machine I auditioned for Power
Rangers as I was doing war machinery :
did it in my hotel room and we was
actually about to go to the club like we
was I was Club ready
bite the [ __ ] this [ __ ] up and London
y'all I have no idea are you
Wow and I'm bushi going club ready ready
holy [ __ ]
That's not me that's my workplace custom
jumpsuit right now oh my god okay all
right so you in London okay you do your
Power Rangers audition in like yeah do
you hear how that sounds what thank you
I swear it was a self it was a horrible
self tape I know it was bad audio and I
know that's why the director I know
that's why I didn't had to call me and
see who I was because I'm pretty sure no
that just means that just means that I
don't matter that you impressed them and
they were like we need more than just
this aisle to shake that's what that was
don't sell yourself short
would you book the part I'm sorry if you
got an angel it's 20 this reminds me to
set up um diner
hey yo keep this diva made them get
CAPRISA
[Laughter]
I need a box he had a box of Capri Suns
on set okay but anyway you in London so
we my director calls you right yeah and
and he was just like um RJ I like your
take on Billy and we're gonna read
through this and that so we read through
it and then I didn't think I was gonna
book it to be honest cuz everybody who
is everybody had this script you know
I'm right right right right and so I'm
like ain't no way in hell that you're
gonna look in this big old tank you know
I'm saying a fish and find this little
one guppy and be like we like you you
know what you know what I know exactly
how you feel because when I when I
booked workaholics I remember being in
in the room with the other people going
for the second yeah you're like and I
was like oh my god that's the guy from
and that's the guy there's no way I'm
gonna get this but why did y'all send me
on this type [ __ ] like yeah but then
when they called me and told me that
book that I
just like I'm sorry guys I had now your
problem were you when you were kid is
Power Rangers in your wheelhouse as a
kid okay sorry I'm just asked I get a
lot of ass what was behind it okay so
you were like Power Rangers was a thing
for you alright okay cool cuz that's
beyond I was in power rangers my
generation was like Thundercats
oh yeah no Smurf holiday came on boomer
here bear or Toonami you know if you
fade update this and nobody you have all
that [ __ ] I had actual son Saturday
morning cartoons hey Eric listen I I
know okay someone's didn't had a box TVs
with the booty on the back someone did
where did you see where I'm up in the
morning I swear to God I punch you in
the face way to do it nothing ours did
yes we yeah we did you had we did we had
the beneath the what did the rabbit ears
and all that yeah so that must have been
how did that feel to know you were gonna
be a Power Ranger always trippy
it was tricky because it's like as a kid
right if that's something that you
looking for you were pretending to be a
power that's why you do that's why you
do your moves and your costume when you
dress up on Halloween right people to
see a this is my version of this Ranger
did you like it look was we had to dress
up as whatever trash bags was in the
crib he was ghetto Ranger hey hey Duval
County we make that more work okay
like my friend Jordan has made a Batman
costume out of black trash bags for afro
island in middle school that junk was
crazy I need to see a picture of that
hey listen the boy was creative I was I
all right cool yeah but it was a whole
different thing I don't like dank I'm a
Power engine out like now when people
look at the blueness I get to be one of
them cuz you know it's a lot of us like
the brook the Blue Crew red crew yellow
crew you know I'm saying but you just a
little rain jur yeah I'm Billy
you know I saw I saw that I was on the
road I saw I was by myself and I was in
a theater by myself you know just just
me sitting there not and I was like and
I love because I only know you from it
was only you and the theater nothing
wrong about me a lot about how we done
oh you did good it did good we want
here about what you think why I didn't
come back but I enjoyed it and I enjoyed
your I thought you did a great job you
became someone else it was like this is
such range from knowing you from I'm
dying up here then seeing you even in
that role it was great and you had a
good time you had to train and all they
have stuff right I need to do that again
cuz you were good super oh I'm getting
fat bro he's kidding what not not like
I'm a metaphor metaphor he's getting out
of shape I should have just had a shot
yeah thank you
over here is fat is just like just not
there okay don't even go any further
alright so I don't know why Power
Rangers didn't come back I thought it
was gonna be like this gonna be a hit
friend I do when I was in that theater
and at the end when the original Power
Rangers caste people came out the whole
theater went crazy and I didn't know
what was going on because it wasn't my
thing you know
but I was like wow this is gonna be a
monster series it's gonna be like a
franchise hit but what happened to be on
I'm asking the same thing we can't
control yeah it's and it's crazy because
so many so many fans and I wish I could
kiss and hug each and every one of my
fans just be like look chill because if
I could I would you know I would be
Billy in two seconds they could call me
tomorrow me like hey you're gonna hunt
doers for four months five months I'll
be like alright I'm need now here's my
question
mmm you were on TV dear commercials
mm-hmm you know you're relatively
good-looking dude you got spice about
you
a little spicy for the Jacksonville
spice on you know but when you went to
Power Rangers now tell me was was the
Power Rangers strange a little bit
better I mean the the female attention
that came at you when you on TV compared
to now you Blue Ranger oh how was that
it's simple for me alright so my Paul
right he always been on something like
all right listen RJ I know that you know
girls they they I hit a beautiful you
know they're Queens but
you don't want to be broke I was like
what does that mean he's like look you
don't want to be broke so you focus only
on that you gonna be broke do you not
gonna have either you know I'm saying
it's just like rrj ham do your business
and do you have the time and it was just
so much more attention from Power
Rangers from you know just in general oh
yeah yeah that was the first time I was
on time squared it was the first time
wheels ever on two streets at one time
that was like it was a lot that power
and just kind of rocked off for me you
know I'm saying I'm like damn I got to
do this part good I gotta do this just I
was so excited for people to see that
[ __ ] yeah it was good man dang I'm
really good at riding hood' out Dean did
this thing like direct and wise and it
was cool because all the other Rangers
like those my nose my brothers and
sisters for real like we see each other
like that's the thing if Flutie didn't
live all the way in Bethlehem we would
see him all the time if Naomi didn't
live all the way in Jerusalem we would
see her all the time you know and if
they could see maybe like being out
there the Bermuda Triangle you know like
well no he was in Atlanta I went and
seen Decker onset of stranger things hey
Suz Christo's he's another like miracle
story Power Rangers was his first thing
things is his second in a throws out
bang bang yeah and I'm like I love it so
tell me what did you think of your
experience about I'm dying up here like
when you first book that like what did
you think of it I was lit because all
right so I used to watch royal bouncin
[ __ ] like a lot you know I'm saying
older movies ATL type [ __ ] boys in the
hood like I just like to older things
you know and that's from growing up with
my paw watching like all my dad's on
cw17
type [ __ ] like that stuck with me and so
when I when I read today from I'm dying
up here
it was just like Dawg this is me on
paper where you from oh he from
Jacksonville mmm cool what he damn that
sound like RJ you know I'm saying even
though it was based off of somebody a
yeah yeah it's nothing yeah like me
that's crazy
but the
characteristics were like kind of cool
so when I read the script and I read the
character I was like yo Adam about to be
somebody they lie it was um yeah I know
what you're saying I remember I remember
just thinking like wow there's gonna be
such a cool project and Jim Carrey it
yeah but she was especially Jimmy like
did you think it was gonna be that
dramatic though now first did you know
well I I gave I gave the I guess you
could say the space forward because of
what Jim did and like all of his older
stuff I'm like fun with Dick and Jane to
where he showed that range and so it was
like did you ever thought like oh maybe
this could possibly also be dramatic cuz
yeah yeah yeah yeah because like he
shows so much range from like from from
even movies like laiá laiá you know like
that was the first time I've ever seen
Jim seem like he's about to cry on some
[ __ ] like don't go from SNL to this like
okay cool but that shows the range so I
gave a lot of I guess you could say
creative space I mean I guess to be
written like I didn't write anything off
you know especially because I knew
there's a story about his life so his
life isn't all fun and giggles yeah I
remember like I'm gonna be at that table
read the first table for the pilot you
know it was just I wasn't even a table
read it was like but the table he was
crazy it's like I was like the first
time I'm like in a room with Jim Carrey
and like I was sitting next to Alfred
Molina and Sebastian so I felt like I
was in a Marvel movie you know cuz
here's Doctor Octopus and in which a
soldier and I was like oh my god do your
[ __ ] right do your [ __ ] right you know
like that table read you know retain
read you looking at the thing like oh
please let me make the me make sure I do
this I think that [ __ ] fell are so ii
table read that we have for when we
started shooting when we started
shooting I was creeped
scared all that [ __ ] just because of
like looking at y'all you know RJ you
know if you get one word wrong which I
did yeah yeah but might be a real would
you there was talk after what I was like
look RJ is [ __ ] everybody in there they
can't fight you better than I
you can walk all the ants other than
Andrew because andrew is like the most
feistiest ginger I've ever seen in my
life and I was like alright RJ if
anything they're gonna pick on your
reading and you swing on their sort of
Duvall [ __ ] I was like eh
there's gonna be my blackballed day
right here but not it was cool man like
just being on set forever uh Adam was
somebody that definitely look forward to
playing every day like school coming
coming and said I'm dying up here it was
[ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] if they called
me at 4:30 2:30 in the morning like I'm
up with my eyes we just all like it was
such a good like camaraderie that we all
yeah for every from from yeah hey wait a
mother you make a movie about goddamn
line oh yeah they could make a movie
about the making of that earlier from
the from behind the scenes to in front
of the cameras off set to like personal
friendship we got a [ __ ] family
for real life yeah but we still in our
group chat
we still weirdos we trying right no
every now and then we like sin a little
Mike Mike will be scaring me sometimes
Mikey hey hey I'm gonna have him on 2 X
ha ha but he got a new war movie coming
out yeah he's doing it he cut his hair
you such a little buzzy man everybody's
doing their thing you know which is cool
you know I'm not leaving you I like
seeing all the things you like I said
white boy Rick that was great thank you
bro yeah that was a great I know you
really liked doing that one yeah white
boy Rick was a it was crazy and in the
main dude right Richie Mary you know
this kid is a savage like he's such a
savage now he's like modeling and stuff
he got another project he's working on
and I'm just like Richie he went he came
from like horrible type [ __ ] like you
wouldn't think that Richie would be what
he is you know I'm saying just from you
know his situations back home you know
I'm saying not to without radio
commercial guy it was and it's like it's
like he took [ __ ] and made it into gold
you know I'm saying I always respect him
for that you know I'm saying cuz he put
his family in a way better place he put
himself in a way better place mentally
you know I'm saying and to watch a kid
that
I met on a movie set right growing to
such a mogul of a person right just on
his own level like to his friends you
can tell his friends look up to him and
that's the [ __ ] that blows my mind you
know I'm saying cuz he's younger than
probably all of them and it's like no
out of all of y'all oh jeez this young
one is showing y'all like the way to
getting out of y'all situation and he's
not looking back to this you know yeah
yeah part about it I'm just like Dawg
you know it's like it's hard to look
back like it's like why I look back when
you like it see like where you are now
well I mean even for yourself right I
mean I'm sure like I definitely wanted
to go back to Jacksonville I ain't gonna
say like you see yourself living in
Jacksonville no no I used to you know
I'm saying like even after I had reached
a little bit of success because it's
like even person wise like I don't feel
nobody real in LA right gosh you have
all the work and [ __ ] that you want but
you still gonna be miserable when you go
home right that's no way to go you just
want the ability to be able to like go
back and forth or for you but you got a
little la in you now to you like being
out here you want to be in London all
you like being in LA because it's like I
don't get a watch watch my back as much
you know I'm saying like is it watch
your back what's going on have you oh
you so Caucasian so Jackson feel like
everybody they act sometimes like RJ why
are you so loud and this and that right
and I can tell another duval person when
I meet another Dulal person because it's
like we loud because nobody makes it out
of Jacksonville Florida like it just
doesn't have really you know I'm saying
not saying everybody died in Jax be like
oh we showed that no but like people get
complacent there they lived there it
grow there and that's just it you know
I'm saying or you get your ass shot in
Jacksonville you know I'm saying like to
be honest it's not no safe place people
act like oh yeah no the [ __ ] it's not
okay like I don't like the fact that I
still got people that live there but
that's all it they that's what they
notice but they know and it come on
and so the most thing I can do is pray
but like I love my city my city built me
you know I'm saying like if you rip open
RJ you'll just see a little sack you're
gonna fall out all out of here I'm
talking
like from the landing all the way to
Pippa Street you know I'm saying like
that's just it and so to come out of
that that situation to be able to show
my homies like hey yo this here is fun
so if you do this do that like now I'm
investing more I got my homies talking
about investing like my friend Candace
she got a bomb escape a skate shop and
all that kind of Stella mom actually my
friend Jordan and his dad just opened
the skate Express in Jacksonville
Florida you know part of it because by
the way people don't know they just dude
is a like a world-class skater about
world class you and your Instagram just
going backwards and you blitz and shoe
ball on my feet well what's next next
well this year we bout to [ __ ] some [ __ ]
up 2019 me and my brother Rob aka cease
way to DJ we got some like goofy ass
tracks poppin you know it's just fun
don't get into the music business now no
oh I thought I was dropping something oh
I thought I was dropping an exclusive
are you like no that's not my MA
we just attack and we just attacking the
the the aspect of creating musically
well so you still okay so you're gonna
produce music no no I'm gonna just make
sure that all of my [ __ ] is out now like
I got mixes and [ __ ] I got songs and
[ __ ] right that that we work it sounds
like you in the music business know it's
not if I was in the music business I
would be like hey somebody sign me I'm
trying to do this and trying to put it
out like this like not enough I know
that my brother Rob has a dream and I'm
there for okay so you help your brother
I'm there find his way anything anything
that was what's up on the acting front
though on the act in front we asked War
Swamp Thing move movie TV I can say that
and then what do I do before that oh
yeah we got I'm all [ __ ] work so much
now but you don't even remember how to
work you down I'm good grief we still
got a couple well we got a few more
right
did you do black oh yeah I love that
show
yo it is crazy as [ __ ] yeah you know
what oh man
that episode that Robert Townsend was on
you know Robert Townes was playing like
the superintendent of the school oh uh
uh you know it's just like he did it was
such a real conversation they were
having and I thought man on national TV
well you know he was like I'm head
negative charge he said it on TV I can
say that on TV but it was like okay they
really they just it was such a like
authentic way to write your will just
drop the line yeah yeah drop this but
it's cool so you know I haven't haven't
finished watching this is it for season
the newest season yet a new season so
you weren't okay so now I wasn't on last
season okay good all right I was like
did I miss you no all right we look at
you out there doing it we trying to
smack it right now you know and then we
got a few more projects next or this
year all I'm saying next year I think
I'm I think I'm busy until like me and
it's kind of good my team is smacking
[ __ ] I love them each and every one of
them that's like my baby I need your
team to be my team yo we all need
somebody it's just crazy
like we got one in New York I've been
wanting to film in New York for so long
yo so you got something in New York you
don't be all over the place New York you
know well New York is your kind of town
you've been in New York before right
yeah yeah when you did it yeah I did
yeah that's your kind of town yeah lay
open till 4:00 a.m. yeah I just hot you
know what are one of my long lasting
memories on it the set was you and you
had the grill guy oh yeah great come
through the grill guy came and I was
like who are you
who are you he had a grill guy come to
say yeah all right so that was only
because it was a few weeks before my
birthday that's right you had a big one
hands yeah and I'm sounds ridiculous and
you needed a grill for your Brianna
Goldberg for his birth let me let me
explain
there was no gold grill it was what was
it a platinum girl I wasn't plan I don't
do all that extra [ __ ] oh so sorry you
don't do the extra [ __ ] he said I don't
know these but like look so so awesome G
[ __ ] people get grills nowadays just
because they think it looked cute back
where I'm from we get grills because
what we say out of our mouth we mean it
and it's worth some [ __ ] whether that's
some oh is that the purpose of a grill
that's me right what's gold is coming
out my mouth no you're just gonna
respect what the [ __ ] I'm saying and
what I'm saying is gonna be true you
know I'm saying like no not-not-not
trying to sound like a certain type of
way but also said you know certain way
of status you know I'm saying you got a
ten wall [ __ ] know you got money if
you got homes you know I'm saying
there's no you about that you know I'm
saying like you can't just be out here
low you should not have a grill we play
at the back of it if you do take it
throw it in the trash stop being a bum
and you go get like your whole thought
process I'm like like that's how you let
people know you rolling deep no not not
that you rolling deep that's just how
they see it that's how they see it me
when it comes to like me my homies the
people that I grew up with the people
that see my like my city so I'm saying
that's why we put them in our mouth like
it's not because we know gangsters and
this and that is just like and it's also
like a little bit of sauce and finesse
it's like baby I got your house in my
mouth right now like for real for real
I can spit your rent right there type
[ __ ] but it's not it's not like when you
it don't need to beat it that's why you
can get a whole like gold set but have
one diamond tooth in the back that's
worth more than all of that you know I'm
saying like did you ever grew up with
some diamonds in it that's none of your
business
why did Greg come to the set Brody all
right all right on that note I want to
thank you I love you too
I hope we work together again in the
future cuz like like I said when I look
at all I see when I look back on him
like my my all-time favorite scene for
you and I was season one at the episode
ten when I come to the I come to the
club where you at we had
interaction at the bar maid I was
something really [ __ ] even Adam was like
you know a guy's those I know we felt
that when I looked when I saw it though
what I was like I really felt something
I was like wow we really did
and then what all they did in season two
where it was just like our story I
almost wish it would have been like a
spin-off show but I like I like how in
most of the show they always show the
almost like Big Brother little brother
combat ability yeah also like the [ __ ]
did I give you and how it's like you
don't know I dunno just trust me it was
good it wasn't all hunky-dory yeah yeah
yeah it wasn't beautiful like oh yeah I
love the Argo yeah fought we fought we
fought that was another mother I'm on
our favorite scenes remember dad when he
was on the thing oh yeah we had we had
the whole argument through the hallway
how long been on daily that thing was
like nine hours you shot that alright
son we had some really funny that was it
was great stuff I enjoy I enjoyed every
minute that and I enjoyed that you came
in on rhythm with Griffin I appreciate
that and I wish you all the success I
know you you you you're gonna be huge
and I love that you're very thoughtful
and selective about what you do you know
I mean so it's not like you're just
gonna be any old crap
um so I look for big things from you and
ladies gentlemen that's been another
episode of riffing with Griffin and this
is my man
RJ Kyler and thank you for listening
everybody good night or am you die or
what is it nighttime no it's not get you
a grill only if you can afford it don't
be trying to be all boozie boozie out
thank you
[Music]